they knew it was comedy Unleashed they
knew what we do the ethos of the club
absolutely not fishing for a reaction
because I thought well this is the
Edinburgh Fringe I know we had the
cancellation of Jerry salowitz last year
but that was after there had already
been a performance and then in that
performance some members of Staff saw it
and got upset and so they canceled the
second night I never thought that they
would cancel preemptively a show I
thought what I thought what would happen
is we might get a few activists turning
up on the night protesting or whatever
and I couldn't be bothered with that I
didn't really seriously think they would
uh the venue would actually uh cancel it
um and it and so rapidly uh so yeah I
was proven wrong quite quickly actually